hay espacio para el compromiso en el
controvertido tema de la reforma de las
pensiones el presidente en funciones
emanuel macon lleva tiempo prometiendo
aumentar la edad de jubilación de 62 a
65 años pero mientras persuadió a los
votantes en esta semana de campaña dice
que estaría dispuesto a rebajar el
objetivo a 64 años y retrasar el
calendario como estoy escuchando como
ustedes no puedes ir viendo la mano el
domingo por la noche quiero reunir a la
gente y luego decir no quiero cambiar
nada el horizonte los 65 años como edad
legal en 2031 puede ser completamente
adoptado podemos pensar en cláusulas de
revisión mario lepe la rival de extrema
derecha de macon tachó la medida de
estratagema y de intento descarado de
apaciguar a la opinión pública y con
servicio extra mancini yo los franceses
son muy inteligentes que todo el mundo
sabe que se trata de una maniobra de
manuel macro para intentar ganarse a los
votantes de izquierdas desde elector de
bruce y la realidad es que impulsará la
jubilación a los 65 años es obsesión de
obsesión le bien quiere dejar la edad
oficial de jubilación en 62 años y bajar
las 60 para las personas que empezaron a
trabajar de los 20 años
ambos candidatos quieren ajustar las
pensiones al iniciar la inflación
la macro dice que el sistema se está
quedando sin dinero y que hay que
revisar las pensiones su primer intento
de hacerlo en 2019 generó una reacción
generalizada provocando protestas
masivas y las huelgas de transporte más
largas desde 1968
durante la pandemia dejo de lado todo el
programa de reformas pero ha prometido
llevarlo a cabo si vence a marie le pen
y gana su segundo mandato